des anges pour agir contre le comique 19
voilà comment sont définies ces
personnes venant en aide aux patients
atteints du coronavirus perturbée par un
système de santé au bord de la dérive
les quarante deux hôpitaux bolivien en
capacité de traiter le kobe 19 sont
complètement saturé à santa cruz villes
boliviennes n'a plus touché par
l'épidémie
un groupe de volontaires travaillent
pour prendre en charge les malades
gratuitement quitte à s'exposer au virus
c est mieux compris par la loi oui c'est
très compliqué vraiment à cause de
l'usure physique que nous avons nous
essayons de nous nourrir du mieux que
nous pouvons ici ils ne nourrissent bien
ils nous donnent des vitamines
psychologiquement nous devons toujours
être positif nous lever chaque matin et
dire que ce sera une meilleure journée
que nous allons sauver plus de gens nous
devons leur donner les premiers soins
les stabiliser ces dernières semaines
ils se sont déplacés dans plusieurs
villes avant de trouver un hangar
d'environ 5000 mètres carrés dans celui
ci ils peuvent accueillir en moyenne
jusqu'à 200 patients la première semaine
a été quelque peu stressante à cause de
tout ce qui s'annonçait peut-être qu'au
début nous avions un peu peur mais après
nous n'avions plus peur bien sûr j'ai du
respect pour la maladie et le virus mais
je n'ai pas peur c'est pour cela que je
suis ici
avec plus d'1 25 million d'habitants
santa cruz est la plus grande ville de
bolivie elle aurait enregistré plus de
la moitié des cas confirmés dans le pays
d'après l'université johns hopkins la
bolivie et la huitième nation la plus
touché d'amérique latine